in today's world
the results of scientific research need
to get out to the public domain as soon
as possible
partly because academia has become
highly competitive and authors need to
show their recent work for the purposes
of funding
job applications and career progression
in general
besides timely dissemination of research
results is required to accelerate
scientific progress
this is particularly important in some
fields such as biology and medicine
where it can influence health care
related developments decisions
and policies and in computer science and
information technology
where the pace of scientific progress is
very fast
the need to share research findings
immediately and the growing frustration
of scientists
at the slow pace of academic journals
has led to the trend of distributing
preprints
what is a preprint a pre-print is a
completed draft of a scientific
manuscript that is uploaded by the
author on a public server
often it is the same version of the
manuscript that is submitted to a
journal
once the manuscript is uploaded it goes
through a quick check to ascertain that
it is scientific in nature
it is then posted online within a day or
two without peer review
and is made freely available for
everyone to view
revised versions of the same manuscript
can be uploaded later on
but the older versions also remain
there are several sites that host
preprints often known as pre-print
servers or repositories
while some of the pre-print severs host
papers from various disciplines
others cater only to selected
disciplines
the oldest and most popular one is
archive which was created back in the
1990s for distributing physics preprints
the site currently hosts papers from
various disciplines such as physics
mathematics computer science and
statistics
the main players in the field of the
life sciences are bioarchive and pure j
preprints
nature also has a pre-print server
nature proceedings
for biology medicine chemistry and earth
science papers
social science and humanities pre-prints
can be posted on social science research
network
some of the benefits of publishing a
pre-print may include
no delays the most obvious benefit of
using preprints is that it removes the
element of delay in the journal
publication process
and others can benefit from your work
immediately
open access depositing your work in a
pre-print server is a great way to make
your research freely available to all
scientists across the world
this is also known as green open access
establish priority at a time when many
scientists across the world might be
working on the same research idea
putting up a pre-print can help
establish your priority on an idea or
discovery as pre-print servers generally
mention the date on which the article
was
posted receive valuable feedback on your
work
once you have posted a pre-print you can
send the link to fellow scientists
asking for their feedback sometimes
scientists spot an error in your paper
and comment
on it you can use such feedback to judge
the quality of your work and improve it
before you submit it to a journal
this will increase its chances of
getting accepted by the journal
get early attention papers posted on
pre-print servers are usually citable
and thus you stand a chance of being
cited even before your paper is
published in a journal
if scientists like your study they might
even share it on social media
thus you can get attention for your
research even before it is officially
published
provide evidence of your research
funding agencies and hiring committees
often want to see evidence of your
recent work
thus delays in publishing can be
extremely damaging when you are applying
for grants or for a job
preprints are extremely useful under
such circumstances
increased chances of collaboration and
invitations to meetings
conference and seminar organizers are
often on the lookout for people to
present work that has not yet been
published
a pre-print increases your visibility
and can attract meeting organizers
as well as potential collaborators and
gain visibility for a broad range of
findings
novelty is often a prime criterion for
being published in a journal
thus it can be difficult for authors to
publish null findings or replication
studies
pre-prints eliminate this problem by
providing visibility to a much broader
range of findings
however there are some concerns about
preprints
the most important concern that the
scientific community has about preprints
is that they are not peer reviewed peer
review is an essential quality control
mechanism to weed out essentially flawed
or poor quality studies
additionally without peer review there
is a possibility of incorrect
information reaching the general public
through preprints
this can be potentially harmful in areas
such as climate science or vaccine
safety
thus some kinds of work may not be
appropriate for dissemination through
pre-prints
another possible problem is that
scientists might upload articles or
findings prematurely just to claim
priority